[Music]
time now for final exam we learn who at
Fox has been paying attention to the
news keep in mind it's our job to do
that who's been doing his or her job
this week's defending champion is fox
news headlines 24/7 anchor and tech
correspondent for this show Brett Larson
is challenger Katie Katie Freitas editor
in chief of the daily walk through and
one of the world's great experts and
video games oh thank you well thank you
for keeping abreast of that burgeoning
industry I appreciate it
I do try all right you know the rules I
think your pardon but to our viewers who
may not here's what they are handsome
buzzers I'm gonna ask the questions the
first one to buzz in gets to answer the
question you have to wait until he
finish asking it in order to answer each
correct answer is worth a point if you
get it wrong you lose a point best of 5
wins are you ready ready as I'll ever be
question 1 Mark Zuckerberg just got
grilled on Capitol Hill and was asked
repeatedly about censorship at Facebook
of two conservative sisters these
sisters are famous online for supporting
President Trump who are they and silk
diamond and silk know these are people
I'm asking about yeah they're the
contribute Oh John okay great I'm
totally kidding impersonator they are
let's see if you're right I'm gonna suck
have a question for you
let me tell you something right now I
dominance silk is not terrorism why is
Facebook censoring conservative bloggers
such as Dimond and silk this is
dangerous
I believe is that diamond insult
everybody knows diamond and soap
including Jeff all right congratulations
thank you beginner's luck again okay
okay cuz we hired a coach here it is
which UFC fighter is out on bail tonight
after grabbing a hand truck and throwing
it through the window of a bus in
Brooklyn New York
oh I don't Conor McGregor Conor McGregor
boy you are upon this is it common
burger I don't know let's check the tape
UFC champion Conor McGregor turned
himself in to authorities last night
following his rampage
Dasia at the Barclays center
yeah Wow I got to give mad props to
Jared max for that one though cuz you
know I scoffs the idea of toxic
masculinity but if it exists that might
have been that might have been throwing
a hand truck hands Rock doesn't press
like the Mongols across the Russian
steppe right you are sweeping through
these motions let's see if you can keep
it going question 3 which member of the
royal family had the world in hysterics
this week when he or she jokingly
compared a noisy helicopter to
presidents Trump and Obama Katy Freitas
I don't remember the Queen mean Queen
what's her face of what country the
Queen is it the Queen
[Music]
Wow that's our judges impressed is the
Queen adequate they're saying it is
Katie all right all right here on the
board one did she bring any question for
here it is the city of Los Angeles is
fighting global warming by taking an
unusual approach won't be surprised to
hear that this approach involves paint
what is the city doing paint it involves
paint its huffing paint until the
problem goes away no they're gonna hug a
tree every time they paint a wall it
knows the streets our judges are saying
if it's something for like Freitas I
have no idea it's have something to do
with the Sun and the heat well
presumably it would happen to do with
the Sun can you be more specific if it's
something about reflecting the heat from
the Sun maybe off the paint that they're
putting on the ground I have no idea
what does it have to do with inflecting
the Sun off the street maybe mad problem
lying to the tape we go the city of Los
Angeles is using taxpayer dollars to
combat climate change by painting its
streets white the pricey project is
expected to take 20 years to complete
while costing the city nearly $40,000
per mile dude you just made that up
you should be a global warming engineer
oh no no that's the extent of my
intelligence on that well it's that's
revealing at many levels but I'm
impressed that you got it I'm now I'm
terrified all right this is it so the
wind heated to maybe she'll make up this
one - final question Illinois's
senator tammy duckworth just became the
first sitting US senator to do this
while in office you didn't wait for him
to finish she's pregnant and she's gonna
have a baby first female senator to have
a baby you know
as a senator did i katie gets to answer
for president senator here i have a baby
first and i just want to say that i am
reflecting the judgment of the judges I
make no independent judges I'm merely a
neutral arbiter here a puppet controlled
by me so Katie you're yes first senator
to give birth hmm mirroring brat yeah
who busting Early's response let's see
if you and him were right senator tammy
duckworth of illinois has given birth to
a baby girl making her the first senator
to give birth while in office and our
congratulations to her and little baby
miley and my congratulations bittersweet
okay wait okay we're I don't know Oh
since we have a technicality we're gonna
throw in one bonus question
Oh the bonus question always remains the
same and the judges have told me to make
it up on the fly oh and I don't know
what they're gonna do with the answer
what is the capital of Burkina Faso the
former African country formerly known as
Upper Volta has a capital called what
wah ha dugu that was it can i chime in
for sexual pandas no you may not
that is effective go in there you all
were great
and this way but you're welcome you're
welcome it worked out maybe you did a
remarkable job feeling your way I'm a
good listener after that okay so you win
the coveted Eric whemple mug which shows
Eric whemple at his well he's a segment
on our show and you can drink your
coffee of that every morning how does it
feel that was amazing thank you for
joining us
Bret thank you thanks for having me back
tucker great to see you that's it for
this week's final exam